well tonight a family receiving some
closure after a breakthrough in a 41
year old cold case for decades tammy
corrine terrell was known as jane arroyo
grande doe her body found in 1980 in a
desert area in henderson as kate houston
reports the original detective on the
case never gave up hope
41 years ago police say drivers found
terrell's body near arroyo grande and
lake mead parkway which is now the 2 15.
with an id confirmed police are now
focusing on finding terrell's killer
someday i knew we'd find out who who she
is someone will find out who did it john
williams was a detective with henderson
police for 35 years and the first one on
this case i was working homicide for
several years and
this was just one that
i
basically took home with me police say
17-year-old tammy corrin terrell
attended the rosswell state fair on
september 28 1980. she was last seen
with a man and woman at a restaurant a
week later her body was found in
henderson investigators were able to use
new dna testing to find two of terrell's
sisters and identify her tammy sisters i
will tell you we're tremendously
grateful
to finally know
what happened to their sister despite
being unidentified for four decades the
williams family kept her spirit alive
helped paying for terrell's burial costs
and visiting her every year they were
able to speak to terrell sisters i
wanted to tell her that her sister was
not forgotten we've always remembered
her kate houston live local now
police also tell us terrell died from
blunt force trauma so now they're asking
in the community for any information to
help close this case